[Musique]
bach trop cirad dorsale is plus
communément appelée mouche des fruits
est un fléau pour les cultures
fruitières et légumières à la réunion
les agriculteurs sont inquiets des
dégâts causés par ce ravageur sur cette
exploitation de manguiers jean claude et
robert a perdu l'année dernière 50 % de
sa production
attaqué par cette mouche là je suis on
regarde la membres comme ça on va pas
avoir la piqûre
mais c'est déjà un fouillis piquer les
hauts comme les bas de l'île sont
infestés par la mouche des fruits
mobiliser la fédération départementale
des groupements de défense contre les
organismes nuisibles sensibilise
également les particuliers dans la
surveillance de la prolifération de
cette mouche avec comme méthode de lutte
la prophylaxie la prophylaxie c'est
récupérer les fruits gâtés au sol mettez
les dans un sac plastique fermé le
fermer le bien et vous pouvez le laisser
au soleil ça permettra de tuer les
petites larves qui vont qui vont éclore
le département aux côtés des
agriculteurs s'engagent dans cette lutte
une enveloppe de 200 mille euros est
consacré à financer les moyens de lutte
mises à disposition des professionnels
pour protéger leurs cultures
nous avons mis en place d'aucune aide
qui consiste à aider à acheter
donc les matériels de lutte à hauteur de
50%
il y a bien sûr les premiers dispositifs
qui consiste à faire de la capture donc
de ces mouches notamment des mâles mais
d'autres dispositifs après
expérimentation d'autres dispositifs
pourront être mises en place
les acteurs du monde agricole se prépare
déjà cette année à subir des pertes de
production
face au danger que représente la mouche
des fruits la lutte et la surveillance
sont désormais l' affaire de tous
[Musique]